[Music]
so of course hilarious you you get to go
to shows like the Emmys now and I'm just
curious do you like award shows like
that's got to be I don't know that
something that you enjoy is that
something that you look forward to oh I
love them I live for them I've been
watching the Emmys and Oscars since I
was little I cry at every single award
every single you don't I do
oh really like the technical Awards
you're crying well I don't go to those
oh I know but every time I watch I cry
every time I even cried a little at the
Emmys that I was at because ty burrell
one was a friend of mine and I was you
know the ugly hmm yeah I do
see we're crying and you're emotional at
those things and so did you used to I
mean you watch the shows when you were a
little you know imagine because I I just
know in my heart I'm gonna win an Oscar
and so I used to have
okay we're gonna front um I used to
imagine winning and I have my speech
ready and you got your Oscar speech
ready I do is it okay if we can we know
we're gonna say um well I would I would
think you know the creators of whatever
show or producers whatever Oscars so the
film and then I would say you know I'm
just a Jersey girl who came to LA to do
stand-up and my mother when I told my
mother was moving to LA to do stand-up
and be an actor and she would be like
really and I was like yeah and she said
well you know if you do it don't
half-ass it and so I would say mom here
it is
hole ass
[Applause]
see because I get really mad about that
yeah yeah my mom'll get mad too